which I find to be so funny is
you've never watched the show
I've never watched one episode I don't
like it but apparently people do yeah
Todd and Julie Chrisley's son Grayson
has never watched Chrissy knows best and
doesn't plan to yeah I don't like it but
apparently people do you know we we have
a lot going on in our lives every day
and you know we've got a lot of kids on
his big sister Savannah's unlocked
podcast the 16 year old makes the honest
confession about the reality show he's
been on since he was a kid do you love
your life
all right this is Grayson and he is the
love of my life
hereditary
what's crazy is some of the people that
are going to be watching this podcast
have watched you grow up on TV I haven't
even watched myself grow up on TV
to touch on
you've never watched the show
I've never watched one episode as for
why Grayson doesn't watch I don't think
it's interesting I don't like it but
apparently people do
oh wow so this is the most
um honest Chrisley we've got here people
find me funny really I don't even find
myself funny
that's the thing I think two you were
used like you you grew up on TV so that
was your life so there was no reason for
you to go back and watch it I know
Chrisley Knows Best premiered on the USA
Network back in 2014. in a year we'd
probably spend 300 000 sometimes
every piece of clothing that our
children wear I think that any family in
this country has gossip and chatter
um I think that ours is just now going
to be broadcast to a much larger level
um people can't say anything about us
that we don't already know
so we're not concerned with what other
people's opinions are we're concerned
with what goes on in our home
as Grayson grew up on the show that way
of life is something he would
what
wife like for you
as a kid like what do you remember I
don't know anything different
like what do you ever remember thinking
as a kid because you had you had a job
no I mean I was just I didn't understand
what was going on but I was like I mean
I have to do it I don't have a choice I
had fun with it because I didn't
understand it and the older I got it was
more like it was a job oh I gotta do
this I thought it was cool but the cool
wears off after a little bit Grayson's
appearance on the podcast comes amid the
family's recent struggles Not only was
Todd and Julie sentenced to a combined
19 years in prison but Grayson was also
involved in a car accident in November
obviously completely totaled but you're
okay I'm fine you're fine you got a
little thing the truck's not fine
no but I'm fine but despite the drama
Savannah told E.T just days prior to her
parents sentencing that the family was
staying strong there you know what
they're pushing through it's worth we
put our faith in God we definitely don't
but our faith and the system I've never
seen two people my parents be so
steadfast in their faith and in prayer
in the end the truth will prevail may
get harder before it gets easier but we
have faith
[Music]
thank you